professionals and the essential workers
for allowing us
the opportunity to continue working this
season so once again congratulations
to the lakers and lakers fans everywhere
look forward to the ring ceremony
tonight genie
thank you commissioner and now please
welcome lakers governor
jeannie buss i'm going to take a second
to speak directly
to lakers fans we miss
you so much the team misses you
but someday soon we'll be together and
when we are together we have something
special to celebrate um
until then um we have some rings to give
out
but before we do that i would like to
show our appreciation
to those lakers who are not here tonight
javale mcgee rajon rondo
dwight howard danny green
avery bradley troy daniels
dion waiters j.r smith
and demarcus cousins winning number 17
means you are forever part of our lakers
legacy
just as the lakers are forever a part of
yours
let these rings be a symbol of that
and a huge congratulations and thank you
to our lakers here tonight
staff and players in the most difficult
of years
you lifted our spirits and brought joy
to our city
and to all our nba counterparts we wish
you well this
season but please know on behalf of the
best
fans in the league our mission is clear
to defend our trophy
[Applause]
thank you genie now let's take a moment
to recognize the team behind the team
the lakers staff please join the lakers
executive team
in celebrating the group here tonight
and the staff watching at home
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight we're joined by some incredibly
special presenters
partnering with the ucla health we have
enlisted workers on the front lines of
the pandemic
truly champions off the court be a part
of our celebration of our lakers
championship team
and help introduce our coaching staff
hi i'm elvira i'm a clinical nurse at
ucla health
hi i'm donna ellis and i'm a nurse at
ucla health
hi i'm rameen i'm a nice doctor at ucla
health
i'm here to present assistant coach
quinton crawford
miss championship friend and i'm here to
present assistant coach mike penfordy
with his
championship rings here to present
assistant coach miles simon
this championship group go liquors
hi i'm jason and i'm a respiratory
therapist at ucla health
i'm here to present assistant coach phil
handy with his championship ring
go lakers
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi i'm rick i'm a special projects
manager with facilities at ucla health
and i'm here to present assistant coach
lionel hollins for this championship
ring
go lakers
[Applause]
hi i'm chante walton the director of
infections prevention at ucla health
i'm here to present assistant coach
jason kidd's championship ring
go lakers
[Applause]
and now we are joined by some special
guests to present rings to head coach
frank vogel and vice president of
basketball operations and general
manager
rob palenko
hi i'm jen vogel i'm alexa and i'm
mariana and we are here to present my
husband coach frank vogel with his nba
championship ring we are so proud of
your dad and everything you accomplished
this season
i can't wait to see it in place and we
love you so much
hi i'm kristen palinco i'm durham blanka
i'm emory polinka
i'm carol palinka and it is our joy to
present rob palenka with his nba
championship ring we are so
proud of your perseverance through
hardship and your hard work that took to
get to this moment
congratulations and
[Applause]
and now for the presentation of
championship rings for our 2020
world champion los angeles lakers
tonight we're joined by those closest to
the team
who truly understand the sacrifice and
challenges
of becoming nba champions
duvante kiko we would like to present
you with your championship ring
you continue to miss us every day you
are so deserving of this accomplishment
we love you and we're proud of you let's
go lakers
as last i just want to tell you that i'm
so proud of you
what's up we love you so much
congratulations
we're proud of you we love you we're
extremely happy for you
for bringing the first uh ring home
let's get more rings man let's get more
ricks come on
we love you she makes us
hi i'm shirley and i am taylor one
tucker's mom
tht and we're here to present him with
his nba championship ring
we are so proud of you congratulations
[Music]
[Applause]
hi we're the morris family and we're
here to present my husband
mark keith morris
[Music]
with his championship ring hugs and
kisses
go lakers
[Applause]
and we are here to present our dad jared
dudley's
championship ring i love you dad i'm
proud of you
and you inspire me you follow my dreams
hi daddy
i love you and we are bffs forever love
you
i love you and i'm so proud of you
this is janet cook and i'm here to
present my son quinn cook
with his hate championship your sister
i love you and congratulations to you
and your whole team
you've worked so hard and daddy's
looking down on you
sharing your championship with you and
with his favorite team of all time
the los angeles lakers
[Applause]
hi i'm keri kuzma and i'm here to
present my son
kyle kuzma with the 2020 nba
championship ring
i'm proud of you and all of your hard
work and accomplishments
congrats kyle
[Applause]
hi i'm mike hi i'm jackie as proud
parents of alex caruso
we're here to present him with this nba
championship ring
we can't wait to see the ring and your
team shine this year
go lakers
what's up laker nation it's the caldwell
pope family and we want to congratulate
our champion kentavious caldwell pope
on becoming a 2020 nba champion you
worked so hard for this congratulations
babe we are so proud of you
we love you daddy
[Applause]
hi anthony we're so proud of you nala
and i are extremely happy and proud to
present you tonight with your first ring
we are so proud of you one of your
biggest accomplishments have been
scratched off your list with many more
to come
we let you so proud of you
congratulations again
daddy
hi i'm candice i go to the i promise
school
and i go to the primary school thank you
for everything you've done for our
foundations and congratulations
keep up the hard work we are family we
are family
we are family hi i'm gloria lebron james
mom
and i'm here with his uncle t and his
uncle curt what's up everybody
it's bryce and i'm going to be
presenting my dad lebron james his 2020
championship
ring we're here to present lebron with
his 2020 championship minute
congratulations snapchat we're proud of
you you've earned it
congratulations dad i'm really proud of
you all the hard work you put in
congratulations dad love you peace
[Applause]
lakers fans and now please welcome our
head coach
frank vogel
i want to just uh start by echoing
genie's comments and thanking the
players
that can't be here tonight that were
with us to help win this championship
uh thank you guys and to the players
that are able to be here
you showed last year what a talented
group of individuals can accomplish
if they buy into being a team and uh
can't thank you enough
congrats guys love you guys and
to our fans we cannot wait until it is
safe enough for you guys to be back here
at staples center
so we can perform in front of you and
celebrate all this stuff with you guys
we love you
thank you we love you
what it do it's your boy big snoop deal
double g
laker nation what's happening shout out
to all of the players the coaches the
staff
the employees and all the fans like me
up there
but first and foremost we want to say
thank y'all for winning that
championship
17th for lebron's 17th year as you see i
got my championship trophy home
so lebron this your 18th year you gonna
get us that 18th
trophy lake show 2021 let's go let's
kick this season off
in a real way lakers
lakers fan please join me one more time
in celebrating
the 2020 world champion
your los angeles lakers
[Applause]
jack kenny you've been there
with full arenas people going crazy and
that moment i
would be hard to
unless you've experienced it hard to
describe
they did the best they could in at
staples tonight i think the family was
it was a nice touch
uh and seeing those videos but on those
nights when it's full and they're
roaring what is that like shaq that nice
for everybody
like like snoop said that the people
that are handing out peanuts and sodas
uh the trainers the assistant coaches
especially family
and you know for guys like uh me and
kenny we
worked hard to get there you know to
finally get there and just
you know say we have a we have a
championship ring it's it's great
and and the respect you get in the city
oh my gosh yeah like i was already
getting respect but i thought i won
i can go to any restaurant and eat for
free forever
and then imagine getting two and getting
three even now when i go back to la
they don't charge me yeah yeah i mean it
is a different scenario
um the appreciation of no one makes it
alone
that shaq just said we all know that not
only just the fans but they're very
close people to us that helped us get
there for me
i don't i don't even own my champion